Donald Trump finally came clean about
his health did you did you hear about
this good that's why I'm here we all
watch dr. oz right mine he's a good
doctor Donald Trump went on dr. Oz right
yeah that's the way a presidential
candidate should talk about his health
Donald Trump admitted to dr. oz that he
is overweight he loves fast food and he
doesn't exercise yeah in a related story
Trump just won Wisconsin yeah this is a
cool announcement the White House has
announced that America will accept a
hundred and ten thousand refugees next
year meanwhile meanwhile Canada
announced if Trump wins will accept 110
million refugees
[Applause]
we're all gonna live in Ontario I don't
you heard this in light of Hillary's
illness Trump is now attacking her
stamina yeah during a campaign rally
yesterday Donald Trump said you think
Hillary Clinton could stand up here for
an hour
yeah then he debuted his new campaign
slogan I can stand up for an hour the
hours up he just falls over it up his
hair falls off and flies away the sound
it makes true story
Ivanka Trump abruptly ended an interview
with Cosmopolitan magazine because she
felt the questions were unfair yeah of
course it's understandable most of us
wither under the intense political
grilling of Cosmopolitan
but see though yeah a lot of people talk
about the city it is true I've Anka
Trump cut short an interview with Cosmo
because of what she said was all the
negativity yeah which is weird because
all the interviewer said was see her dad
as Donald Trump right thanks one guy
it just took that one guy turned it all
around kind of a cute animal story in
the news a 100 year old tortoise named
Diego 100 years old has now fathered
over 800 offspring which is why today he
was the first tortoise in history to be
drafted into the NBA
the Duggars of the TV show 19 Kids and
Counting are adopting a 20th child yeah
not because they wanted one because it
came free on their punch card got a
complimentary car walk a woman in Oregon
sounds like I'm starting a limerick a
woman in Oregon who was hospitalized for
e.coli after eating Chipotle is suing
the company for free Chipotle she says
she doesn't want money she wants more
Chipotle yeah that's all part of
Oregon's right-to-die law sorry
oh okay that kid earlier got a going
pull alone this should be inspiring to
you a man is getting bar Mitzvahed
at age 113 yeah they're hoping the
attendance is better than last year when
he got circumcised cuz no one no one can
[Applause]
[Music]
visualize it it's pretty good
you got it now yeah
[Applause]
you